[Music]
this morning we remember charlie watts
the legendary rolling stones drummer who
stayed out of the spotlight that
followed the band everywhere watts died
yesterday at a london hospital several
weeks after an unspecified medical
procedure he was 80 years old
mick jagger honored his band mate of
nearly six decades tweeting a photo of
watts with a big smile keith richards
posted an empty drum set with a sign
reading closed here's a look back at
what's brilliant career
in a band known for its brash
personality charlie watts was its quiet
backbone
for more than half a century his steady
beat anchored the rolling stones which
he formed alongside mick jagger keith
richards bill wyman and the late brian
jones watts spoke to 60 minutes ed
bradley in 1994. and i always consider
myself a drummer you know and uh
so that's to keep the time and
help everybody else do what they do you
know
i don't really like
solo type things
his drumming skills self-taught by
listening to jazz greats like charlie
parker and duke ellington it's one of
the faults in my playing because i never
learned to play
the stones had searched for a drummer
for months before finding watts and
feared he might be too talented for them
but he ended up playing on all 30
rolling stones albums and on every tour
despite his sharp fashion sense he shied
away from flashy drum solos and the
attention that came with international
super stardom watts defied all the
stereotypes that came with being in
arguably the world's most influential
rock band while jagger and richards
mugged for the camera he was shy and
introverted as drugs ravaged the era's
bands including the stones watts
indulged but then quit cold turkey
he married his wife shirley in 1964
and they stayed together and raised a
family
[Music]
[Applause]
watt's passing comes about three weeks
after he pulled out of the band's
upcoming tour citing health reasons
i knew he was ill but i didn't know
it was this beatles legend paul
mccartney paid tribute in this video
message condolences to the stones should
be a huge blow to them because
charlie was a rock man of fantastic
drama
[Applause]
and from what i understand even though
he was ill and and had been replaced for
the upcoming tour uh this came as a
surprise to the rolling stones too we
still don't know exactly we don't know
what happened we don't know what
happened he seemed to have such a low
key kind of cool i like when he said i
don't like solo type things right he's
one of the biggest bands in the world he
said at one point i wasn't interested in
being a pop idol and i still think it's
silly
yeah i mean he went on tour with the
rolling stones for every tour and you
think how much fun would that be well in
the 90s he said every night he went back
to his hotel room alone and drew his bed
he has a sketch of every bed he ever
slept on for the entire run i love that
i love it that's a different kind of
rock a different kind of rock star
dignified i mean keith richards wrote in
his book he said charlie watts has
always been the bed eye lion musically
and that's he really was the backbone of
the band i really do like the shot of
the drums with the sign that just says
closed i think it's really poignant and
really tells the story no it really
startled me when that came across
yesterday one other fun fact about how
times change when they were trying to
get charlie watts they thought they
couldn't afford him right because he
wanted five dollars a week five pounds i
think five pounds yeah yeah which seemed
like a like a fortune keith richard said
they they actually shoplifted so they
could raise the money i don't think he
was kidding about that